yeah you guys you reached out to us to
be on the podcast and dude i was super
surprised
i was i was i was super stoked i was
also super surprised because i wonder if
you know this but i got into tattooing
right i became a tattoo artist like a
couple years back yeah i i heard about
it yeah i'm a very big fan of you god
damn since the very beginning though
because i'm 33 you know and i've been
i've been doing this for 26 years i
appreciate that so from the very
beginning i know about clown school
everything look right
so i i get into tattooing a couple years
ago and it was right around the time
when you got this crazy face tattoo yeah
and uh and i saw that you were following
me on twitter so i hit you up i was like
yeah
i hit you up on twitter said um i missed
it i said uh yo yo dude i'm really good
at tattooing i even included in the dm
like my portfolio of to show like that
that i was actually doing good tattoos
yeah i wasn't like trying to tattoo your
face or anything but i was like yo
i promise you if you had your tattoo
gear here i would let you do a tattoo on
my face um
we'll come back yeah yeah we might want
to come back no no for real but the
thing was that when i sent the dms then
all of a sudden i was unfollowed by your
twitter account
so i don't know uh i i thought that i
had uh offended you or somehow
i don't know i was and and then
that's that's kind of strange here's
what a sensitive little petty
[ __ ] i am i'm like oh he didn't follow
me i unfollowed him
so i thought we weren't birds anymore
you're like you know what [ __ ] aaron
carter stupid-ass twitter
and then and then you reach out to to be
on the podcast i'm like [ __ ] right on
dude i would love to give you a tattoo i
don't know if i feel comfortable
tattooing your face but then again my
philosophy about tattooing is that uh i
only wanna
to to work on people who are already
pretty
[ __ ] tatted up so that the stakes are
low yeah well you know your face
qualifies yeah
yeah dude
thanks for watching that clip and if you
live in america there's a good chance
that this big badass tour bus is coming
to your town with my bucket list tour
what is it well it's an x-rated show
full of all the stuff that i would have
never have been allowed to do for
jackass and a lot of it is flagrantly
illegal so it's adults only and if you
live in any of these states then you
better go to stevo.com and check out my
tour schedule hurry up and get your
tickets too because it's
selling out everywhere
yeah dude
[Music]